vamos a multiplicar 4 por 2012 ajá o
mejor mejor que te parece si borro esto
este 2 si lo hago un poco más sencillo
claro 4 por 201 ya sólo para simplificar
las cosas entonces 4 por 201 lo que
hemos visto en vídeos previos a mí me
gusta escribir poner esta anotación el
número mayor arriba y el número menor en
este caso el 4 aquí en el lugar de las
de las unidades entonces ya tenemos aquí
201 por 4 y justo como cuando
multiplicamos un dígito por dos dígitos
se hace lo mismo solamente aquí son tres
dígitos vamos a multiplicar primero por
este 4 por 1 es igual a 4 y pongo el 4
en lugar de los de las unidades ahora
vamos con el siguiente dígito
4 por 0 el 0 está en lugar de las
decenas entonces 4 por 0 es igual a 0 de
hecho 0 por cualquier número es igual a
0 y el 0 va aquí ahora por último falta
un dígito recuerda ahí falta el 2
estamos multiplicando por tres dígitos
entonces 4 x
4 x 2 es igual a 8 el 8 lo pongo aquí
abajo
y la respuesta es 804 perfecto entonces
ahora bien el olor lo genial de esto por
qué funciona esto cuando yo multiplique
4 por 1 eso me dio cuatro cuando
multiplique cuatro por cero
me dio cero y ahora multiplico cuatro
por dos pero no es un 2 es ahora es 200
por eso me da 800 4 4 por 200 es igual a
800 entonces lo que se está haciendo a
fondo es decir 4 por 201 es lo mismo que
4 por 200 es igual a 800 4 por 0 es
igual a 0 y 4 por 1 es igual a 4 800 más
04 es igual a 804